hey this is presh to Walker have you
ever used math stack exchange it's a
question and answer site for people
studying math at any level and for
Professionals in related fields
I came across a curious interview Riddle
That I thought you'd find interesting
if 3 and 4 is 8 4 and 5 is 50 5 and 6 is
30 and 6 and 7 is 49 what is 7 and 8
equal to
the post received 47 upvotes which is
very good
and I'll mention it's an interview
riddle so there were some objections
about the ambiguity of notation or the
possible open-endedness of the answer
this is not a mathematical Olympiad
question where everything is defined in
epsilon Delta terms this is understood
to be a fun interview riddle where it is
an open-ended question and applicants
are tested on how they think through
problems because the interesting
questions in life are open-ended what am
I going to eat today what am I going to
wear which job should I take these are
not completely well-defined questions
the interesting part is to understand
how someone would think about the
process and what they would speculate
the answer would be
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so here's how I approached it
first let me just put circles around
these X's so that we don't confuse this
with regular multiplication
we have a binary operation of A and B
and we need to figure out some sort of
way to combine the numbers A and B
so one way to approach this problem is
let's just use normal multiplication
a times B so 3 times 4 is 12 4 times 5
is 20 5 times 6 is 30 6 times 7 is 42
and 7 times 8 is 56.
now looking at the desired results 850
30 49 and the regular product of the two
numbers there's no simple multiplication
factor or difference of numbers
what's interesting is the pattern also
increases we have 850 but then it goes
down to 30 and then 49.
so we're not just going to multiply or
add the numbers because in those cases
the numbers would just keep increasing
monotonically
so let's try some more calculations
let's try a squared B
so 3 squared times 4 is 36 4 squared
times 5 is 80 then we have 150 252 and
392. and once again there's really no
simple multiplication factor or
difference of numbers that's going to
explain the pattern
so let's continue
let's try a b squared so in this case we
have 48 100 180 294 and 448.
now if we take a b squared and divide it
by the pattern we have we end up with a
curious pattern so 48 is 8 times 6. 100
is 50 times 2 180 is 30 times 6 and 294
is 49 times 6.
so we see we're going to take a b
squared and we're going to either divide
it by 6 or 2. so let's consider this for
448 so 448 is equal to 74 and two-thirds
times six or it's equal to 224 times 2.
now all of the other results are
integers so we might guess that we would
want an integer so in this case we'll
eliminate 74 and two-thirds and we'll
just go with 224.
so if we were just to speculate what the
answer might be we might just guess that
the answer is 224 and in fact this was
the correct answer to the interview
riddle
so now the question remains is how can
we write a simple function that would
encapsulate this
so what we can do is we'll look at the
greatest common divisor of a b squared
and 6.
so 48 and 6 the greatest common divisor
is 6 106 it's 2 180 and 6 is 6 294 and 6
is 6 and 448 and 6 is 2.
so we figured out a way to explain this
pattern so we might speculate that A and
B combine to be a b squared divided by
the greatest common divisor of a b
squared and six and that is one way you
can explain this pattern
but maybe you found another pattern that
would explain this
I am very curious if you found any other
pattern that's simple please share it in
the comments so that we can all learn
other ways and what other possible
answers might be there's a saying that
anyone can answer a well-defined
question but it takes a genius to work
out an open-ended question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]